[Music]
The Fallout franchise is among the most
popular and successful RPG games ever to
Mark the 25th anniversary of the game
series those responsible published a
first image of the upcoming live action
series which has been in the works for
quite some time the image shows three
people wearing Vault 33 jumpsuits as
well as the illuminated opening of the
vault which leads into the dangerous
World outside the protected bunker thus
we can expect to see on the one hand the
isolated life inside the Vault protected
from radiation and on the other hand the
outside world destroyed by a nuclear war
this would also be consistent with the
previous reports in terms of story most
Fallout games revolve around an
individual who grew up in one of the
numerous vaults or at least spent an
extended period of time there and later
meets the Flora and Fauna mutated by the
nuclear fallout even within the vaults
things are not always harmonious not
only are you squeezed together with lots
of strange people in one place but
sometimes you also have to put up with
secret experiments the latest game
release is Fallout 76 an online game by
the developers Bethesda and obsidian
which was never really well received in
spite of great Ambitions many fans still
yearn for Fallout New Vegas which was
published in 2010 and is regarded as one
of the best games ever in the
role-playing genre whether the Amazon
series will be able to convey the
atmosphere of the Fallout games in a
series is doubtful nevertheless we are
curious to see what the responsible
parties will make out of it sadly a
release date is not known yet
rumors about the upcoming Star Wars
movie have been circulating since the
beginning of the year mainly triggered
by deadline it was suspected that Damon
Lindelof was working on an upcoming Star
Wars film and even a possible director
was supposedly known well now the rumors
were indeed proven true and it was
revealed that Damon Lindelof best known
as the creator of lost is in Creative
charge of writing the first Star Wars
film since 2019. the director has now
also been revealed namely charmeen obey
chinoy who has already won two Oscars
for The documentaries Saving Face and a
girl in the river the price of
forgiveness the Pakistani filmmaker has
previously worked for Disney as well
having most recently directed the MCU
series Miss Marvel nothing has leaked
out about the plot of the new Star Wars
movie yet however the flick is bound to
attract a fair amount of attention since
the franchise is in need of a successful
movie release after so many series there
are other Star Wars movies being worked
upon behind the scenes however this
movie bio chinoi and Lindelof is sure to
have the best chance of being released
in the near future we'll keep you posted
on further announcements
on October 23rd the finale of the first
season of House of the Dragon was
released with episode 10 The Black Queen
many are naturally curious to know how
the conflict among the targaryens is
going to continue shadowrunner Ryan
Condell who is now solely responsible
for the development of the series after
the departure of Miguel sapochnik spoke
about the future of the Game of Thrones
prequel in keeping with the current
finale of House of the Dragon the focus
is on the so-called Dance of the Dragons
which will cover a large part of the
remaining series it will continue to be
based closely on the original book by
George R.R Martin who published the
novel Fire and Blood in 2018 and which
is structured like a history book in it
contributions from various maesters can
be read although these are not
necessarily written in an objective and
clear Manner and pursue a different goal
depending on the agenda of their
respective naster for the series team
this translates into greater artistic
freedom in future storylines the often
perplexing change of characters has also
come to an end by the way since many
plot lines in C season 1 were told over
many years there were also different
actors for the characters as children
teenagers and adults respectively with
the progress of the series however this
has now gradually reached an end so that
we can become accustomed to the current
actors shooting for the second season
will kick off in January of 2023 and
it's not yet known what happens
thereafter for fans of the series this
means a longer waiting period which will
certainly extend to at least 2024.
in a few days the last film from phase
four of the MCU black panther wakanda
forever will be released over the past
two years the film has been heavily
impacted by the depth of King t'challa
actor Chadwick Boseman as he was already
set to play the lead role in the sequel
immediately after Bozeman's death those
responsible decided to reconsider the
plot it soon became clear that out of
respect for Bozeman's Legacy there would
be no CGI replacement for recasting
filming finally started with a new
script in June of 2021 however the
question remains what happened with the
original version director Ryan coogler
recently addressed this in an interview
with The Hollywood Reporter in fact he
said the sequel was very much about King
t'challa and focused on his Evolution as
the leader of wakanda after the events
of Avengers endgame coogler spoke of a
gigantic movie that would have delved
deeply into the psych of King t'challa
however he was unable or reluctant to
confirm whether Neymar was also planned
as the main villain in the original
version the present version is very
different different as you can already
tell from the two trailers here it
becomes apparent that Bozeman's depth is
processed through the passing of his
movie character which can be seen for
example in the graffiti thereby his
death is handled in a sophisticated way
and at the same time makes room for the
presumed main character shuri she is
embodied by Leticia Wright and is the
sister of the late King t'challa in the
film it is likely that she will
henceforth act as Black Panther in the
MCU more details will be available very
soon since black panther wakanda forever
is due for release on November 11 2022.
what are your thoughts on the current
approach of having King t'challa pass
away in the MCU as a proper tribute to
Chadwick Boseman will this do justice to
Bozeman or would you have wished for
something entirely different in order to
pay him his last respects on screen feel
free to write us your opinion in the
comments
news about the upcoming saw X began
circulating a few months ago apart from
many speculations it was also
anticipated that actor Tobin Bell would
return to his iconic role as jigsaw at
the time critics argued against the
rumor since his film character had
actually died at the end of Saw 3 and
was later only seen in flashbacks now
however it has been announced that the
meanwhile 80-year-old Bell will indeed
portray a living John Kramer Alias
jigsaw in fact Belle has sustained the
film series for years with his
performance and was the highlight of the
respective films along with the
ingenious and equally brutal traps
producers Mark Berg and Oren Coles
recently called it an exciting reunion
thus muzzling the last Skeptics the
story will be set prior to the third
film and will therefore not be a sequel
but a sort of prequel another tourney
behind the scenes is Kevin gruter who
already handled the direction of Saw 6
and saw 3D filming will begin shortly
but we still have to wait about a year
for the release as saw 10 or saw X is
expected to hit theaters on October 27
2023
it has now been 16 years since the first
of the two film adaptations of the
popular horror franchise Silent Hill
came out released in 2006 the movie
revolves around the main character Rose
who has to deal with the terminal
illness of her daughter Sharon she sees
a faith healer as the last resort for
her child's recovery however things
don't go as planned and so she ends up
in the mysterious small town of Silent
Hill she has no choice but to realize
that her daughter has disappeared off
the face of the Earth the town is home
to all sorts of horrible monsters while
there is also a weird cult that is up to
no good later it turns out that Rose and
Sharon are trapped in a nightmarish
alternate World from which there seems
to be no way out along with the movie
and its sequel Silent Hill revelation
there are over a dozen video games some
of which now enjoy cult status
especially the memorable creatures have
stuck in one's mind including for
example the disturbing Pyramid Head
which was first introduced in Silent
Hill 2 in 2001 or the twin victims from
Silent Hill 4 the French director
Christoph gons is back for the third
movie installment which is apparently
titled return to Silent Hill the script
is already complete and the movie will
focus on the events of the game Silent
Hill 2 in a live stream Gans disclosed a
few details the main character will be a
young man returning to the mysterious
town in which he met the love of his
life but what he finds instead of a cozy
atmosphere is to be an utter nightmare
as an audience you can look forward to
old and new monsters and the appearance
of the brutal Pyramid Head is deemed
probable as well meanwhile video game
fans have plenty of new games to get
excited about including Silent Hill Town
fall the prequel Silent Hill F and a
remake of Silent Hill 2 which is widely
regarded as one of the best in the
franchise so we are eagerly awaiting
more news about the upcoming return to
Silent Hill movie by the way even before
that you can look forward to the series
Silent Hill Ascension which will be
released as an interactive format next
year as for the movie there is no set
release date yet
with Black Adam the newest movie from
the dceu is currently running in
theaters and those who have already seen
the movie might have been pleased about
the one or other surprise one important
person in the future of the DC film
universe will at least be Henry Cavill
as he personally confirmed via Instagram
last week more than five years after his
last appearance in Justice League The 39
year old is now officially coming back
to his role as Superman after this had
been prevented by those responsible in
the years before the plans for a new
Superman movie are consistent with the
statements made by Dwayne Johnson during
the promotional phase of Black Adam
after all Johnson often talked about a
potential clash between his character
and Superman and allegedly also
advocated for cavill's return behind the
scenes at the moment it is not known
what exactly the upcoming Man of Steel 2
with Henry Cavill will look like but we
do hope for more news soon that goes
beyond the mere announcement
laughs
[Music]